[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier weil wir so alle politik berichten
wir euch schon seit längerem davon wie
afrika begonnen hat seine position im
roulette rad des wirtschaftlichen
erfolgs zu verändern wir haben zum
beispiel ausführlich über ruanda
äthiopien gesprochen zwei länder die bis
vor wenigen jahren noch zu den ärmsten
des afrikanischen kontinents gehörten
die aber jetzt entgegen aller
erwartungen einen wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung erleben
trotzdem bin ich mir sicher dass wenn
ich euch die folgende frage stelle die
antwort immer ähnlich ausfallen wird was
fällt euch als erstes ein wenn sie an
afrika südlich der sahara denkt nun ich
bin mir sicher dass die antwort für die
meisten dieselbe ist wie immer armut not
und katastrophen aber wie ihr euch schon
mehrfach gesagt haben beginnt sich
dieses klischee in vielen fällen zu
verändern die zukunft ist nun mal nicht
in stein gemeißelt und bei afrika
handelt es sich ja nicht um einen
homogenen einheitlichen staat mit
anderen worten wir werden auf diesem
kontinent sehr unterschiedliche zustände
und trends vorfinden
nehmen wir zb die situation von kenia
und tansania obwohl die beiden länder
eine gemeinsame grenze haben fast
gleichzeitig unabhängig wurde und beide
volkswirtschaften zum zeitpunkt der
unabhängigkeit ein ähnliches
einkommensniveau hatten unterscheiden
sie sich mittlerweile gewaltig heute
sind die kenianer nämlich gemessen an
der kaufkraftparität das heißt unter
berücksichtigung der preisunterschiede
und ganz 80 prozent reicher als ihre
nachbarn gemessen am bip pro kopf nach
ihrer unabhängigkeit wurden beide länder
zu diktaturen aber wir haben kenia den
übergang zu einem demokratischen
marktorientierten modell schafft warten
seine jahrzehnte lang einer
sozialistischen diktatur unterworfen die
große unternehmen verstaatlichen und die
menschen zur arbeit im kollektiv
wirtschaften zwang
ähnlich verhält es sich mit simbabwe und
botswana die ebenfalls eine gemeinsame
grenze haben obwohl simbabwe 1980 sogar
bei weitem das reichere der beiden
länder war eine situation die sich von
der heutigen vollkommen unterscheidet
denn heute ist botswana ein land das
sich für stabilität und eine freie
marktwirtschaft entschieden hat nicht
nur sieben mal reicher als in ware
sondern hat auch ein höheres
pro-kopf-einkommen als länder wie
kolumbien brasilien und ecuador
es stellt sich also heraus dass wir wenn
wir unsere entdecker uniform anziehen
sehr unterschiedliche zustände in
subsahara-afrika finden können
unterschiede die sich in zukunft wohl
nur noch mehr verstärken werden
dieses phänomen hat die schnell
wachsenden länder südlich der sahara
bereits als afrikanische löwen berühmt
gemacht denn es ist ihnen gelungen nun
einen starken aufschwung zu erleben nach
jahrzehnten massiver korruption gewalt
systematischer bereicherung organischer
eliten und des einflusses des
afrikanischen sozialismus einer
politischen ideologie die in der zweiten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von
der sowjetunion probahn genährt
unterstützt und vorangetrieben wurde
denn es gibt nämlich einen weg aus der
armut aber seid vorsichtig denn dieser
weg ist ein steiniger weg liebe visual
politik zuschauer dieses mal werfen wir
einen blick auf eine ganz andere
geschichte als diejenige welche mit uns
alle vorstellen denn wir als luke sahara
afrika denken seid ihr bereit euch mit
uns auf eine neue reise ist unbekannte
zu begeben und dann lasst uns anfangen
willkommen auf mauritius
[Musik]
die wohlhabendste insel afrikas
mauritius ist eine insel republik die
aus vier hauptinseln besteht und den
indischen ozean liegt etwa 1000
kilometer östlich von madagaskar damit
zählt mauritius zu einem der
abgelegensten orte auf den globus der
sprechen von einem sehr kleinen land
gerade mal 2000 quadratkilometer großen
welches für eine französische später
eine britische kolonie war und das trotz
allem als einziges afrikanisches land
die spitze des index für menschliche
entwicklung erreicht hat der jährlich
von den vereinten nationen erstellte
wird noch in den 1960 er jahren war
mauritius vollständig vom
zuckerrohranbau abhängig heute hingegen
ist es eines der wichtigsten finanz und
tourismuszentrum afrikas sein
preisbereinigtes bip pro kopf schätzt
die weltbank auf 21.000 us dollar das
ganze fünf mal so hoch ist wieder durch
den afrikanischen länder südlich der
sahara damit steht morgen ist sogar
besser da als china aber gut an dieser
stelle fragst du dich vielleicht ok mag
aber wie um alles in der welt schafft
ein kleines abgelegenes inselrat in 60
jahren den aufstieg aus der extremen
armut und wird zu einem der wichtigsten
finanz- und tourismuszentralen ganz
afrika nun ja die lösungen liegen
zuschauer liegt in einer reihe von
politischen wirtschaftlichen
legislativen und sozialen reformen die
das land zu einem der sichersten in ganz
afrika gemacht haben wenn nicht sogar
zum aller sichersten
aber um herauszufinden wie und wann
diese ganze geschichte in gang gesetzt
wurde müssen wir uns erstmal in die 1970
er jahre zurück gegeben diesen
jahrzehnte litt mauritius unter einer
schweren wirtschaftskrise die sie schon
jahre zuvor zusammen gebraucht hatte die
gründe dafür waren die mangelnde
diversifizierung der bitter armen
agrarwirtschaft die hohe
arbeitslosigkeit die zu schnell
wachsende bevölkerung und eine kleine
politische und soziale eliten den
größten teil des wohlstands
kontrollierte und wären reichtum
entstand nicht aus einem fairen
wirtschaftlichen wettbewerb von ihr
versteht was ich meine jedenfalls war
das land angesichts dieses szenarios und
seiner geographischen lage von den
internationalen märkten isoliert und
seine möglichkeiten ausländische
finanzierungen oder investitionen zu
erhalten waren praktisch gleich null
um sich also aus dieser not zu befreien
musste mauritius tiefgreifende
politische und wirtschaftliche reformen
durchführen was als nächstes geschehe
damals keiner für möglich gehalten
besonders nicht im vergleich zu der
generellen situation in afrika moritz
brachte ein umfangreiches reformpaket
auf den weg und genau das schauen wir
uns jetzt mal an
wir können das reformpaket in drei
phasen unterteilen die erste de benoten
den siebziger jahren stattfand und von
den einnahmen ruhig die zuckerrohranbau
profitierte beinhaltet die einrichtung
einer sogenannten exportproduktion zone
so etwas wie eine sonderwirtschaftszone
hierbei handelt es sich um ein
geschütztes gebiet in welchen die
regierung eine reihe von steuerlichen
und regulatorischen begünstigungen
einführte um die industrieproduktion und
den export anzukurbeln
und wisst ihr was wie an so vielen
anderen orten über den wir hier sprechen
war auch dieses experiment der ersten
kontaktaufnahme mit dem globalen freien
markt ein erfolg in kurzer zeit siedelt
sich produktionsunternehmen aus neun
verschiedenen branchen 91 prozent der
unternehmen waren lokal aufgrund der
ergebnisse dieser reformen erkannten die
mauritischen behörden nun also dass der
aufbau einer wirtschaft die auf den rest
der welt ausgerichtet ist sehr sehr
lukrativ sein könnte um dies zu
erreichen mussten sie aber die
abgelegene lage von mauritius
kompensieren und die frage war wie
sollte dies nur gehen nun die lösung lag
eigentlich auf der hand
in der zweiten phase der reformen zu
verstehen oder 80er und 90er jahren
wurde die exportproduktion erweitert und
ordentlich gepimpt um noch attraktiver
für firmen aus dem ausland zu werden
infolgedessen stiegen die
auslandsinvestitionen abermals
sprunghaft an und ein neuer sektor
begann praktisch aus dem nichts zu
florieren der tourismus ein sektor der
für die entwicklung von mauritius von
grundlegender bedeutung war und heute
fast 20 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes ausmacht nicht
von ungefähr ist die hauptinsel auch
unter dem spitznamen big island bekannt
aber damit nicht genug in dieser zweiten
phase wurde auch der kapitalverkehr
liberalisiert eine niedrigsteuer modell
eingeführt viele der bestehenden
vorschriften abgeschafft und zeitweise
sogar das bankgeheimnis implementiert
what happens orange stage ist das
bedeutet übrigens dass das land über
jahre hinweg bis 2019 auf nationalen und
internationalen listen von steueroasen
bzw von nicht kooperativen ländern und
gebieten für steuerzwecke geführt werden
sollte
[Musik]
aber liebe zu schon der punkt ist dass
mauritius auf diese weise eine sehr
finanzgründen marktwirtschaftlich
orientierte wirtschaftsstruktur
entwickelt hat die ertragssteuer für
unternehmen beträgt zb 15 jedoch wird
dieser satz auf 0 0 bis 3 prozent
reduziert wenn es sich um offshore
unternehmen handelt das sind firmen die
ihren steuerlichen hauptsitz zwar auf
mauritius haben die ein hauptaktivitäten
sich aber außerhalb des landes abspiel
in mauritius gibt es außerdem auch keine
kapitalertragsteuer das heißt man zahlt
keine steuern auf dividenden oder
zinserträge
diese wirtschafts architektur welche in
der dritten phase zwischen 90 und 2010
noch weiter verbessert und konsolidiert
wurde führte zu einem richtig der
investitionen im land und zur
entwicklung einer internationalen
finanzindustrie die wirtschaftsliberalen
gesetze zogen banken investmentfonds
manager und versicherungsgesellschaften
und erlaubten sogar lukrative geschäfte
mit capital gesellschaften die ihre
steuerstruktur verbessern wollten und
liebe zuschauer die auswirkungen dieser
gesetze sind gewaltig nach schätzungen
der mauritischen finanzdienstleistungs
kommission zu den organismus mehr als
21.000 internationale unternehmen
registriert werden weltweit verteilt
vermögen ganze 600 milliarden dollar
übersteigt das ist mehr als das
vierzigfache des gesamten bip der
kleinen insel
mauritius mit man all jenes thermen die
diesem prinzip folgen global business
company kurz tbc es dabei handelt es
sich um unternehmen die hauptsächlich im
ausland tätig sind die sind zwar
mauritius ansässig oder her auch noch
steuerpflichtig jedoch werden deren
aktien mehrheitlich von personen oder
unternehmen kontrolliert die nicht in
mauritius nehmen
aber das ist noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange
tatsächlich ist die zahl der millionäre
auf mauritius in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten schneller gewachsen als in
jedem anderen afrikanischen land das
natürlich auch die finanz branche
beflügelt hat nach angaben der frasier
bank hat sich die zahl der auf mauritius
lebenden ausländer mit einem
nettovermögen von mehr als einer million
dollar im letzten jahrzehnt verdreifacht
inzwischen gibt es dort fast 4000
millionäre vor allem aus frankreich und
südafrika und haye die strände die
sicherheit und die niedrigen steuersätze
naja wen würde denn sowas nicht gefallen
aber wartet man lieber visual politik
fans lasst uns mal kurz auf die bremse
treten ich kenne euch nämlich schon ein
bisschen eine steueroase malt propagiert
du uns hier in erst eine insel die auf
dem rücken millionen ehrlicher
steuerzahler zu reichtum gekommen ist
als vorbild für ganz afrika da hatte ich
denn jetzt schon die der bestochen nun
ja liebe zuschauer es ist ganz klar dass
steuerparadiese ein sehr umstrittenes
thema sind auch wenn wir hier über das
einzige land in subsahara afrika
sprechen das ein sehr hohes niveau der
menschlichen entwicklung erreicht hat
ihr habt daher vollkommen recht es gibt
ja durchaus so einige fragen die wir uns
an diesem punkt stellen müssen
[Musik]
war es gut oder schlecht für den rest
des afrikanischen kontinents das
mauritius zu einer art steueroase wurde
wie hat es überhaupt geschafft das
vertrauen so viele internationale
investoren zu gewinnen was hatte
mauritius was ländern wie liberia belize
oder vanuatu nicht hatten die ja
ebenfalls als steuerparadiese und den
steuerfragen als nicht kooperativ gelten
fangen wir mal mit der ersten frage an
viele von euch denken vielleicht dass
die existenz von orten wie mauritius
etwas schlecht ist bei den rest von
afrika sei aber nichts könnte der
wahrheit turner liegen und bevor er
gleich anfangen teuren bildschirm an zu
schreien lasst ist nicht doch erklären
sagte 60 prozent der investitionen von
internationalen unternehmen die in ohrid
registriert sind werden von mauritius
aus gelenkt und sind für die länder des
afrikanischen kontinents bestimmt ich
spreche von minen hotels fabriken
immobilien projekten und so weiter und
so fort wir haben es also mit
investitionen zu tun die
selbstverständlich arbeitsplätze
industrieproduktion und wirtschaftlicher
aktivitäten aller art in vielen
afrikanischen ländern schaffen nicht nur
in mauritius dank dieser aktivitäten
alten die afrikanische staaten in denen
die aktivität angesiedelt sind übrigens
auch steuereinnahmen zum beispiel auf
arbeit konsum oder immobilien mit
anderen worten sie erhalten
steuereinnahmen aus dem reichtum dadurch
all diese investitionen entsteht aber
dann stellt sich natürlich die frage
warum man diese investitionen
ausgerechnet von mauritius aus lenken
sollte nun die zuschauer es geht ja
nicht nur um die frage der besteuerung
sondern auch um ein ganz anderes noch
viel wichtigeres element und das ist
genau das gelegen welches dieses lang
von anderen steueroasen wie liberia oder
beließ unterscheidet
tatsache ist dass mauritius eines der
sichersten politischen systeme in ganz
afrika hat ein system das ausländischen
investoren aber natürlich auch der
bevölkerung selbst ein hohes maß an
rechtssicherheit bietet infolgedessen
verfügt das land über ein rechtssystem
das von internationalen organisationen
als sehr effizient und unabhängig
angesehen wird es gibt frei und
weitgehend faire wahlen ein relativ
hohes maß an meinungsfreiheit und eine
ausgewogene machtstruktur in welcher der
präsident der premierminister und die
nationalversammlung sich die aufgaben
und die macht untereinander aufteilen
und so als gegengewicht fungieren und
das ist noch nicht alles
laut weltbank gerade mauritius zu jenen
13 ländern der welt in denen es am
einfachsten ist geschäfte zu machen und
laut dem index wirtschaftliche freiheit
der heritage foundation ist mauritius
ebenfalls auf das 13 der freiesten
volkswirtschaften der welt und die klare
nummer eins in afrika verstehst wird
also warum genau diese eigenschaft
mauritius zu einem weitgehend sicheren
und stabilen land machen deswegen sich
in weiterer folge viele ausländische
kreditgeber dann das entscheiden ihre
für sub sahara afrika bestimmten
investitionen hier zu registrieren zu
deponieren und von hier aus zu lenken
denn wenn wir uns schon gesagt haben
können eure steuern noch so niedrig
seien ohne rechtssicherheit und
politische stabilität wird euch das
nichts nutzen wie ihr seht fallen erst
so alle puzzleteile ineinander niemand
wird sein geld egal wie niedrig die
steuern sind an einem ort bringen an dem
er am hellichten tag ausgeraubt werden
kann und an dieser stelle fragst du dich
vielleicht okay aber hat der
wirtschaftliche fortschritt auf maurice
überhaupt noch vorteile und reichtum für
die eigentliche bevölkerung von
mauritius gebracht nun das fragst du
dich völlig zu recht denn wir wissen ja
wie diese dinge häufig laufen es
passiert nicht selten vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass wir in afrika sprechen das
ist gute nachrichten am ende nur für die
oberen zehntausend auch wirklich gute
nachrichten bleiben aber die antwort ist
glücklicherweise dass dies immer ritus
nicht der fall ist ihr wollt ein paar
harte fakten na dann los geht's
[Musik]
die abend im land wurde 2009 auf 12,7
gesenkt und die extreme armut im land
praktisch ausradiert worden von den fast
1,3 millionen menschen auf mauritius
leben nur noch weniger als ein prozent
in extremer armut all dies haben die
mauritier mit hilfe eines
durchschnittlichen jährlichen
wirtschaftswachstums von 4,6 prozent
zwischen 977 2008 erreicht dieses
wachstum hat es dem land auch ermöglicht
seinen gini koeffizienten ein maß für
die ungleiche verteilung von reichtum
auf ein niveau zu senken das dem von
ländern wie spanien australien wurde die
in großbritanniens name kommt
das alles zeigt uns das
wirtschaftswachstum hat tatsächlich alle
bevölkerungsgruppen erreicht und
begünstigt die vorliegenden daten
scheinen klar zu machen dass wir es mit
einem neuen afrikanischen löwen zu tun
haben von dem er zuvor vielleicht noch
nie etwas gehört hat aber bedeutet dass
du zwangsläufig dass ein auto mauritius
auf dem besten weg ist sich einen platz
in der rangliste erreichen und
entwickelten länder der welt zu sichern
nun meine lieben zuschauer so einfach
ist das leider nicht aufgepasst
könnte mauritius so enden wie der dodo
mauritius ist nicht nur für seine
wunderschönen strände und sein strenges
bankgeheimnis bekannt sondern auch für
den dodo einen flugunfähigen vogel der
hier heimisch war aber im siebzehnten
jahrhundert nur 100 jahre nach seiner
entdeckung durch den menschen aus stadt
und nun fragen sich die analysten auch
den wirtschaftswunder des inselstaats
nicht das gleiche schicksal droht wie
dem armen dodo der auf mauritius über
jahrmillionen keine feinde besaß und da
hat über kein natürliches flucht oder
verteidigungsverhalten verfügte ihr
könnt er sich ausmalen dass in einem
land das so stark auf tourismus und
international investments ausgelegt ist
die korona krise die kleine republik
sehr hart trifft um euch eine
vorstellung davon zu geben das
bruttoinlandsprodukt steht vor einem
historischen rückgang während das
haushaltsdefizit auf über 20 prozent
gestiegen und die eintragung neue
offshore firmen stark zurückgegangen ist
aber warte ein moment denn während die
auswirkungen der korona krise in diesem
fall höchstwahrscheinlich vorübergehend
sein werden ist das besorgniserregend
sei an diesen inselstaat der wandel den
sein wirtschaftsmodell durchmacht
seit 2008 hat mauritius erhebliche
änderungen an seinem steuer und manchen
system vorgenommen änderungen die
bestimmte wirtschaftliche vorteile
beseitigen mit dem ziel von
internationalen gremien nicht länger als
eine nicht kooperativen steueroase
beurteilt zu werden außerdem baut das
land ein steuermodell auf das dem der
industrieländer immer ähnlicher wird
weil nämlich alle steuersätze allgemein
erhöht werden allerdings werden die
steuern immer noch viel niedriger sein
als in den meisten entwickelten ländern
in der zwischenzeit haben sie aber auch
weitere änderungen vorgenommen um
ausländisches kapital anzulocken
[Musik]
zum beispiel haben sie seit 2008 zehn
die mindestkapitalanforderungen für die
eröffnung eines unternehmens von 100.000
us dollar auf die hälfte reduziert mit
anderen worten mauritius steht vor den
herausforderungen einer neuen rolle in
der es nicht länger eine steueroase mit
völliger anonymität ist sondern ein
musterland mit niedrigen steuern und
wenigen vorschriften des internationalen
governance standards entspricht so wird
zb der staat mehr einfluss haben als in
den letzten jahrzehnten während aber
weiterhin eine hohe attraktivität für
investitionen und kapital gewahrt werden
soll wir sind eine kleine insel deren
möglichkeiten in vielerlei hinsicht
begrenzt sind wir haben keine
natürlichen ressourcen wir müssen einen
vorteil gegenüber anderen haben um
attraktiv zu sein und da denke ich dass
der steuervorteil sehr wichtig ist
präventiv premierminister von mauritius
man könnte sagen dass die idee der
lokalen elite darin besteht mauritius
von einem finanz und tourismuszentrum zu
einer wichtigen drehscheibe für den
handel mit sub sahara afrika zu
entwickeln so etwas wie das singapore
afrikas das tor zu einem noch
unerschlossenen kontinent für
kapitalinvestitionen und handel vor
allem eine brücke zwischen afrika und
asien die frage ist jedoch erreichen die
niedrigen steuersätze und die
rechtssicherheit aus um die gute
wirtschaftsleistung aufrechtzuerhalten
wird mauritius weiterhin ein beispiel
für stabilität und fortschritt für den
rest des kontinents sein oder wird
seinen ausstieg aus dem steuerparadies
da sein das ende der atemberaubenden
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung von
mauritius bedeuten
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer dies ist die geschichte
eines der wohl bekanntesten
afrikanischen löwen gleichzeitig aber
auch eine der erfolgreichsten ein land
welches nicht nur bewiesen hat dass es
auch in afrika möglich ist der armut zu
entkommen sondern dass auch zu einem
vorbild für andere länder des kontinents
geworden ist ein modell das andere
länder wie zb die elfenbeinküste auf
gewisse weise bereits zu imitieren
versuchen um den nächsten afrikanischen
löwen zu werden aber darüber werden wir
in einem zukünftigen video berichten
wenn jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der
reihe glaubt ihr dass mauritius trotz
seines neu eingeschlagenen weges
weiterhin ein florieren der
wirtschaftsstandort bleiben wird und ist
mauritius flaschen oder anfang eines
generellen großen aufschwungs in afrika
wie immer sind auf eure meinung in den
kommentaren schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls ja gibt es mit einem
leicht höheren freuen und vergesst nicht
das abo mit glöckchen um keines unserer
videos zu verpassen vergesst bitte auch
nicht eine kleine spende über den link
in der beschreibung mach's gut und bis
bald